[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
happy week 13 everybody you just tapped
into the br betting squad ride live in
the bleacher report app presented by
giraffe kings you know the deal by now
i'm connor rogers alongside the giving
spirit over here in greg ivory greg how
are we feeling man this season is flying
by right now
season is flying by connor i mean
we're in the christmas spirit here and
you know with that comes hoodies comes
giving so actually connor i'm in the
comments right now i'm in the comments
looking for takes i'm looking for most
importantly i'm looking for winners
zombie please but i'm looking for takes
and i see
levine envy mvp levine mvp says antonio
gibson anytime touchdown is a lot shout
out to you levine mvp you were walking
away with the first hoodie giving out on
today's show i like it i like washington
today too but we'll get into that later
on boldest bets you know the drill by
now this is the show where we're looking
for touchdown scores who's getting in
the end zone we ask you on social we ask
you in the app every single week to send
us your videos and these are the top
selections from this week leonard
fournette coming off a monster week no
surprise there everybody in the fantasy
community is well aware of what him and
joe mixon can do on the ground mike
evans just been a beast since he got
into the league now with tom brady he's
limitless justin jefferson greg i know
you're eyeing that one against the lions
that's a juicy matchup for him today
jamar chase been the offensive rookie of
the year sorry mac jones lovers jamar
has been more impressive miles gaskin
hunter renfro and keenan allen some plus
money choices getting in on the action
gonna be a fun one today so with that
being said
i know you got the hoodies greg we do
that every single week but you got a
little bit more in your pockets tell
them what you're giving away
i'm not only giving out hoodies connor
i'm also giving away two nfl jerseys one
goes to the winning lock legend and one
goes to a lucky commenter like yourself
so get in the comments and do what you
do if you want a jersey if you want a
hoodie i need gifts i need emojis but
most importantly you guys all know what
i need i need winners
only please you could type it out i'm
looking for you guys in the comments
type it out i'm giving away hoodies
let's go connor four legendary picks to
show you last one standing squad ride
leader they get the jersey and their
touchdown score greg is going to boost
those odds with the help of our friends
at draftkings we could all throw a
little bit of money on that why not at
this point let's get into it the first
one is from ford raring tell us who's
scoring a touchdown today
whatever cup this lands in we are
hammering anytime touchdown this week
[Applause]
the chip shot legend one take only going
with keenan allen plus 150 keenan down
only got in the end zone twice this year
but guess what that means he's due right
craig all right second one is from john
john taking on the chip shot legend
let's see the choice
[Music]
[Music]
justin jefferson early christmas money
if it sticks we pick justin jefferson
plus money you got to love seeing one of
the top scoring receivers in the league
at that plus money mark against keenan
allen plus 150 golf legend candy cane in
the christmas spirit legend
greg we're gonna need a little help from
this one tell the people what we need
for match-up number one
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and let me know which way we
should ride should we go with the golf
legend and keenan allen or should we go
with the candy cane legend and justin
jefferson uh
connor i'll hop in here
this keenan allen play
i do see
the the the chargers bouncing back this
week after a tough one last week i i see
a big game from justin herb see a big
game from him so i i kind of like the
king and now and play but i absolutely
love the justin jefferson play uh look
for him to get back on track
he was he's facing the lions defense who
was ranked 29th in passing yards per
game he had a quiet game against the
niners i mean he did face the niners but
uh i look for him to bounce back against
this detroit defense connor which way
are you lean yeah i'm with you all the
way like we said earlier keenan allen
just hard to expect him to score on a
weekly basis right now but more
importantly a lot going in the way
for the way of justin jefferson the
match-up love it against the lions
you're all low for it craig number two
there's not a crazy drop-off when dalvin
cook gets hurt to alexander madison in
terms of workload and production they
still run the offense the same they
still look to give madison 20 25 touches
and he he does a great job with it but i
think when you get into the red zone you
got to get justin jefferson involved
i'll go ahead and say it greg and we'll
see if the comments agree in a second i
think justin jefferson is a lock this
week to get in the end zone yes sir
yes sir i love those vibes connor i
absolutely love those vibes but let me
see if they're vibing with us in the
comments uh i'm in the comments right
now i'm in the condiments i love cabbie
shout out to cabbie candy kane justin
jefferson all the way shout out to you i
love cabbie you are walking away with a
lily uh here we go i'm back into the
comments i am back into the comments i
got wd 13 says justin jefferson one more
one more
uh i got mgo blue 16 justin jefferson
conor i i feel like it's apparent it it
it appears crap my guy justin jefferson
and the plus money
plus 110 is moving on to the next round
all right round one melinda round one in
the books the john john the candy cane
legend going with justin jefferson still
got two challengers on the board and the
next one is a very familiar face in w
trammell we know the kind of damage he
does week in and week out on the squad
rod let's see what w trammel is cooking
up this week
what's up vr nation i heard this machine
have one last lock
[Music]
mike evans
i don't even want to ask how w trammell
pulled off the lock inside the claw
machine and i don't want to ask how many
quarters that cost either the guy isn't
you're right mike evans minus 105 he has
been one of the locks to score as a wide
receiver this year greg you know we like
that plus money but we also know what
you can do with it this is a juicy match
up here in round two
connor i love what you just said because
we know what we do here on the squad
ride
we just odd boost things up man we just
odd boost things up but before we odd
boost anything up i need you guys to get
in the comments and let me know should
we ride with mike evans in the claw
legend or should we stick with justin
jefferson in the candy cane legend
honestly connor i'll be
honest
i'm torn here you can't go wrong
absolutely torn
you really can't go wrong here i mean
before last week mike evans scored in
four consecutive weeks he scored a
touchdown in four consecutive weeks
before last week i see him bouncing back
against that atlanta defense talking
about the atlanta fight
i'm torn connor i'm absolutely torn
which way are you leaking yeah i think
with mike evans basically since antonio
brown got hurt and now he's going to
deal with the suspension while rehabbing
that injury
that's who they look to out of their
wide receivers and we know how good
chris godwin is we know when gronkowski
is on the field he's a favorite of
brady's and we know what lenny can do on
the ground as well but mike evans has
just been mr consistent but justin
jefferson is an absolute superstar i'm
good either way on these greg i'm gonna
let the people tr we usually we swam and
don't worry we probably will try to sway
you for the final round but round two
goes to the people
it's straight to the people uh i'm in
the comments i am in the comments i got
s i f
c picks one says mike evans he gave us
the mike evans gift shout out to you
i'll give it to you guys there it is the
mike evans gift
bobbing and weaving and throwing an
uppercut i got chewie on julian says
evans is a lot against the falcons
defense shout out to you chewie on uh i
got one more in me hold on actually
actually they're back and forth conor i
have to call it how i see it i see
g quinn 26 jefferson is going to light
up the line secondary winners only
please absolutely love that take
connor i'm i'm gonna walk it off with
this one i'm gonna i'm gonna walk it off
with this one i got can no shoei canna
show he says evan
is a luck so with that being said connor
that being said
mike evans the claw legend and my guy w
travel is moving on to the next round w
tremolo is coming in and disrupting
shaking things up knocking people off
final round we got
mike evans on the board we got the old
timer and w trammell but now we got
another pick from pro angler jb let's
see what he's got out there fishing
what's up br betting i'm out here on the
water today and you guys have got to see
what i just pulled in
leonard fournette anytime touchdown
score minus 165.
playoff lenny looking like regular
season lenny right now saving some
fantasy team so fournette minus
165. i think you greg can get that to a
nice place where we feel good about it
mike evans minus 105. we have teammates
in the final round it's not a matter of
what team it's a matter who's scoring on
the bucks and boy do they score a lot of
points final round how are we feeling
about this one where are we going with
it
connor
let me say woo
in the comments need deep breaths in the
comments because this one is
tough this one's tough uh so what i need
you guys to do is get in the comments
give me woo size give me breaths just
tell me who we should be riding with uh
because
i'm torn once again connor i'm torn once
again we talked about mike evans already
but
can we talk about leonard fournette and
what he's done like he's been absolutely
balling four touchdowns last week i mean
come on sitting at minus 165 you know
what we can do here i'm touring connor i
don't know which way to go i'm gonna go
the way the people lead me but which way
are you riding connor which way are you
think we should go knowing where we can
get that leonard fournette line greg to
at least even maybe a little bit more no
spoilers here
i gotta defer to the running back as
great as mike evans has been as great as
that passing offense is
i mean greg he just scored four
touchdowns we're asking for one
one
i'm going leonard for that easy where
are the comments going to take us home
for the squad ride leader of week 13.
my boy my boy justin bodfield he says
look at that move greg lenny all day
he's hot and so are the boys he gave me
a gift i'll show you guys i'll show you
guys to get my boy leonard fournette in
college lsu people over there it is uh
i'm back into the comments i am back
into the comments i got
eli eli
zav eli bezov gave me the leonard
fournette gift he's uh greedy
allah justin jefferson uh here we go i
got brandon degrassi he's got lenny two
touchdowns uh
siffy pix says minus 165 is terrible but
do not work
because we will fix that actually i'm
gonna call it i'm gonna call it i'm just
gonna leave it on that comment everybody
that i mentioned you guys are walking
away with hoodies
connor
it appears we came to a decision
the fishing legend the fish 11 pro
angler jb leonard fournette is the
winner of today's squad ride let's pull
up the graphics so i can show you and so
i can show sydney picks and so i can
show everybody in the comments what we
and only us here on the square ride can
do you guys see leonard fournette minus
165. poof there is the magic thanks to
our friends at draftkings we're gonna
boost that up
from minus 165 to plus 110 check out br
betting socials for a link to the odds
booze send us your screenshots of your
beds let's get rich this sunday send us
your videos
and your celebrations but most
importantly conor
we want winners and we want winners only
please
plus 110 greg that that is uh
that's some of your best work yet on the
show i think everybody should be really
happy with that leonard fournette plus
110 you know what to do get on
draftkings have a little fun with that
one all right the community comment
contest time and shout out to pro angler
jb you get the jersey get the squad rod
leader title well done all right br
betting community stream we ask you who
are you betting on to make or miss the
playoffs the board's pretty even right
now there haven't been a lot of runaways
this year considering how far into the
season we are right now so greg what'd
you get what uh what came your way this
week i know this is when things get a
little crazy people start throwing out
the takes i want to see what we got
a lot a lot came in a lot came in but
before we get started before we get
started with the contest i gotta give my
guy jake
l
estan jacostan i'm sorry there it is
jacob stodd a shout out
because
he's keeping it real too real
one honey well we're out front we call
it keep it a buck mate he's keeping it a
buck with us right here he says no bets
are safe
yes no bets are safe we feel your pain
brother and just for that you are
walking away with a hoodie it's the
season of giving
now
i need everybody that's here right now
to get into the comments and tell me
which of these is the better take i'm
giving a hoodie to whoever you guys
choose so let's take a look at the first
comment from h
green
89.
h39 says like vikings and coles they
both
run the ball
even without dalvin that will be huge
down the stretch
connor
what's your take on this one i like it i
like the thought process right you're
looking for teams that can control the
clock that can rely on their run game
when their quarterbacks aren't clicking
and i think both of these teams are in
situations where they need that you've
got to help wince you've got to help
cousins they're okay but they're not
superstars by any stretch now
love the point even without dalvin cook
that is a scheme proof run offense where
alexander madison comes in and just gets
the job done right away now they're in a
pretty brutal division when you're
staring up at the packers but that
doesn't mean you can't make the playoffs
with that expanded the colts right now i
don't worry about their division at all
i don't worry about their schedule at
all i actually came away from their loss
against the bucks like all right they're
for real they can hang with the big dogs
at least so greg i like this take a lot
i think it's on the money
yeah yeah i like it too we know what the
coach can do with the run game there uh
and like you said even without dalvin
cook the vikings have been able to show
that they could run the football let's
move on to the next comment connor we're
moving on huh 420.
he sent us a gift this is different
connor sent us a gift of bill belichick
gift and it says the patriots are making
it and i think they are i like mac jones
i like him he said he's a game manager
he's doing this in his rookie season
i think he's gonna pan out to be a good
pick for the new england patriots but i
do see them making it to the playoffs
they can run the ball they play solid
defense and they have a game manager as
in mac jones uh what's your take hunter
yeah you're all like mistake do you
agree i do they win in the trenches once
again and it's not just the offensive
line their defensive line with their
rookie christian barmore they get it
done in the trenches on both sides of
the ball uh the rookie quarterback like
you said greg been extremely extremely
efficient we know how well coached of a
team they are and it really doesn't
matter at the end of the day how they
split against the bills or how they look
against the bills because there's a lot
of room in the playoffs for two teams
the bigger thing is that the dolphins
have been a complete dud in that
division where everybody thought it
would be a three-team race they thought
miami would be a tough out new england
would hang around and the bills would
run away with it all really hasn't been
the case at all new england's been right
in the thick of things they look way
better than miami we're gonna find out a
lot about them against the bill so i
like where our usually our comments are
too off the wall for me i like all three
of them this week i had everybody should
get a hoodie if it was up to me
hey shout out to the comments man you
guys you guys make the show i just want
you guys know that you guys make this
show i'm actually in the comments right
now connor giving away more hoodies uh i
got
chris walpole chris walpole he sent us a
hunter renfo gift it's kind of random
it's kind of random but guess what
shout out to you brother you were
walking away with a hoodie uh
they they're riding i i see i see
max maxwell rexella's in the comments
saying h green 89 he likes his take shot
maxwell you're walking away with the
hoodie uh
i got jacob jacob
jacob
c
z nick 24 says ride with lenny talking
about leonard fournette shout out to you
connor i'm just gonna call it here i'm
just i'm just gonna call it my boy matt
dodger's in the comments c burke says
the eagles is gonna win for sure today
the comments is all over the place we
love their takes but i'm just gonna say
h green89 he's the winner of the comic
contest so shout out to you h green89
shout out to your take you are walking
away
with the hoodie well done it's green all
right before we get to our favorite time
the boldest bets we like it when we when
we give them out i don't know how we
like them all the time uh if they miss
but it's time to talk a little player
props right prop lock or drop it we're
looking this week at our favorite ones
from the slayton i'm loving this first
one you got here greg with a guy we have
talked about a lot on this show today
[Music]
that's right everybody i need you to get
in the comments and tell me if you think
these props are a lot or if they're not
and if we need to drop them e
immediately i'm giving away hoodies to
whomever can help us out
let's get right to it all right the
first prop the first prop here we go
connor leonard fournette to rush over or
under 62 and a half yards he rushed for
a hundred yards
and scored four touchdowns last week
connor
talk to me talk to me i i conor they're
facing
we know who they're facing they're
facing
the atlanta falcons
i mean i think this is going to be easy
what's your take you know what i usually
you know me greg i don't like rushing
over props when they get high like this
you get into the 60s get into the 70s
i like this one i think at the end of
the day the bucks offensive line with
jensen with wurfs they are just gonna
maul that atlanta front four i'm sorry
falcons fans you don't deserve any more
pain especially against tom brady you do
not but at the end of the day they're
gonna run the rock and they're gonna do
it successfully and i think fernette is
a smash over 62 and a half these always
scare me but this one does not i think
we see a d 75 80 yards and at least one
teddy
yeah i agree i i agree i think he's
gonna have a good game look for the
bucks to start running the ball more
towards later in the season protect
ombre that's right uh so
yeah i like this i like this a lot uh to
go over let me get in the comments let
me get in the comments and see
if uh
if they're rocking with us i got jt for
mvp says he's going to kill me in
fantasy talking about leonard fournette
shout out to you uh levine mvp and
lavina mep got fournette dancing as a
gift shout out to you uh
somebody said he's been going crazy oh
there it is danny rodriguez said he's
been going crazy yes he's been going
crazy j dilla 85 says over easy all
right that's it everybody that i
mentioned you guys are walking up
walking away with a hoodie connor
let's move on to our next prop let's
move on to our next prop we got justin
her
two throw over or under 291
total passing yards uh it's a battle of
the two quarterbacks from the 2020 draft
class in this one connor he threw for
300 yards 303 yards and two touchdowns
last week herbert currently leads the
nfl in total qbr
can justin herbert lead the chargers to
a bounce back win
after their loss to denver last week
conor do you like this do you like the
over do you like the under do you think
justin herbert is bouncing back at first
glance i love it at second glance to go
over the bengals have not gotten
shredded by a quarterback since mike
white came in for the jets and beat them
their last three games they haven't
allowed a quarterback to throw for over
250 yards but guess what greg all good
things got to come to an end justin
herbert over 291 he's getting 300 today
the chargers are upset in the bengals
i'm feeling good about it i like this
one where are you at do you think
herbert breaks their streak of looking
great on defense lately honestly i i
absolutely do conor i absolutely do
justin herbert needs to show up today he
has to call today tough loss last week
need to bounce back against this bingo's
team and the only way they can do it is
with him i mean with his help he needs
to show up he needs to throw so i'm i'm
i'm going over i'm i'm believing in
justin herbert to show up today uh and
break the streak like you say all
come to an end all good things come to
an end so i'm rocking with the over
let me see what the people
is talking about let me see what the
people talking about i got jay vargas
saying he's bouncing back today i got
little saint 814 says he gets
303 touchdowns shout out to both of you
guys you guys are walking away with a
hoodie i got noi nation says herbert
over that is a lot shout out to
everybody that i just mentioned you guys
are walking away
with hoodies
two player props
two locks in overs big day for fournette
big day for herbert let's keep it riding
who's gonna have the big day it's
boldest bets time been a roller coaster
greg i like what you've been putting out
there lately let's get into it man
let's get straight to it let's get
straight to it connor what i need
everybody that's here to do is get in
the comments and tell me whether you're
riding with me or my boy connor connor
let's get right to it all right you are
riding with so greg these player props
not clicking for me lately in the
boldest bets gonna take this a different
direction and looking for dogs looking
for underdog winners
i'm going with two i like the washington
football team they've been sneaky hot
lately i like what heineken's gotten
done i like their offense and i think
they can upset the raiders on the road
and then we talked about it with the
chargers the bengals have had a really
exciting year but you nailed it the
chargers got to go in and win this game
they got to find a way to get it done so
these are two money line bets plus 426
two upsets let's have a day where are
you going
connor i swear bro i'm about to
lock in right now lock in your your bet
bro i love that
love the two dogs
but we've been talking about justin
jefferson we've been talking about
justin jefferson on this show earlier in
the show you said he was going to score
a touchdown i said he was going to score
a touchdown
so let's talk about that pull up the
graphics so i could show the people
there it is
justin jefferson two or more touchdowns
i mean look it he's facing this lions
defense i told you guys earlier i'll
tell you guys again they're ranked 29 in
passing yards per game the ranked 29th
in passing yards per game look for my
guy justin jefferson and
the vikings receiving corps
and
my guy kurt cousins to have a field day
but i need justin terry i need two i
need two go get it i'm all over it greg
i love it great matchup with the lions
no dalvin cook and as much as we love
madison you gotta get justin jefferson
involved in the red zone when maybe that
run game isn't as dominant still good
not as dominant plus 650 he just did
this a few weeks ago against a much
better defense so
i'm glad that you found this i'm sure
the line's gonna move by the time i walk
out of the studio and try to go home
plus 650 uh comment section ride with
greg but seriously let's take a look
let's have some fun let's hit on some
boldest bets today where what's everyone
saying
uh i got i got seberg says whoa
jefferson for sure is a lock shout out
to you matt dodger said give greg a
raise appreciate that
dodger h johnson 101 says riding with
greg appreciate you brother uh okay here
we go you made you luca says yeah connor
i like it i like it too uh i got xo
ellie it says i'm riding with greg
appreciate you brother and then i got
i got j dilla j dilla
and no no lax jax six as well connor and
i are on the same wavelengths
sippy picks is also rocking with you
connor everybody that i mentioned
everybody you're all walking away with a
hoodie it's love i love connor's parlay
i love it a lot i also love justin
jefferson to score two touchdowns why
not sprinkle both get rich that's what
we do and before
we get out of here and before you follow
those bets and the squad rod booster i
got fournette up to plus 110 do not
forget it
you still have an nfl jersey to give
away to the comment section i didn't
forget
my boy connor did not forget
and everybody that's still here you guys
are about somebody's about to be
rewarded i'm in the comments i am in the
comments connor
and i'm looking for i'm looking for a
good take i'm looking for a good take i
got big mike 13 says brighton with
connor going with my team washington
winners only pleased i don't think that
that's worth
a jersey that's worth a hoodie shout out
to you big mike i'm still looking i am
still
looking connor uh
all right here we go here we go here we
go
noah goldberg noah goldberg won he gave
us sunsets i'm trying to keep this right
here he gave us sunsets connor
the people know what sunsets do does to
my heart they they know what the sunset
vibes does to my heart so what with that
being said my guy noah goldberg watchers
is a true fan he knows
he's walking away with a jersey shout
out to you noah you know what to do to
catch my eye and melt my heart
i love it oh man that's well done
everybody knows how to catch greg's
attention and that is how you get
rewarded good luck with your wagers
everyone today was a blast and jump on
that leonard fournette booster kratzell
our hoodie and jersey winners you know
the deal by now if you won in the next
24 hours you will hear from br betting
check your dms do not forget thanks to
everyone that commented you make the
show thanks to the lock legend we have
pro angler jb the squad ride leader ford
raring john john w trammell long time
legend legend enjoy your football sunday
drop your real time takes in the app
drop them on social follow greg on the
br betting instagram he'll have it
popping all day over there
alongside greg ivory i'm connor rogers
catch you same time same place
next week
[Music]
you